hi guys we're really excited to tell you
that we are coming to Australia right
yeah going to Auckland Brisbane
Melbourne Sydney Adelaide and Perth and
it'll all be happening in November of
this year ticket sales will be on very
soon so we will see you in the future
bye bye g'day might fine fine
[Music]
[Music]
okay I'll change to you bomb yeah okay
you guys be hunters okay wait dad's fog
in here and a bartender whoa because
it's a vape bar duh am I supposed to be
spawned in seeing you guys no wait come
on don't lie to us you can't see
anything I've got some weird out-of-body
thing going on where my body's lagging
behind my it won't let me be it won't
let me be think I wanna just surprised
steel hang on just and wait yeah thank
you thank you
no Tweaker no no peeking give me thank
you I can grab this oh [ __ ] literally
you want to see a joke us a joke yeah
I'm I'm the forbidden dildo
can we alright it's not gonna work let's
just kill mark no wait hang on you don't
know which one I am
[Laughter]
is gone for now thank you
but my legacy lives on I help bad
legacies are still a thing to
opportunity to call mark a piece of [ __ ]
there I don't know I think it was
implied I think the comments yeah it
over it's fair all right can we get a
hint or something more clearly earlier
said you're in quite a pickle
getting a shoot every penis in the room
good shot I gave you that hint like when
Mark before mark became [ __ ] we were
clearly distracted by the job did my
[ __ ] haven't you ever seen a turd and
just been like whoa hang on I got a
tweet this there's also floating
Toblerone wait wait wait
so totally what so totally what's your
favorite maritime book based on a
captain pursuing a whale totally in that
big dick okay that's a different type of
movie it's different one that's the
parody of that one are you the totally
that starred and totally in that big
dick all right wait heard why was there
a turd next to this man doesn't make
sense why was there two heard there's
one right next to this guy as well
there's no like it poo emoji what's he
holding look like that reject that hint
my guess is he was a turd and he changed
to a cellphone and now he I haven't
changed or moved this entire no no no
this room I'm in the couches room okay
all right that was your hint this one's
gonna be my that I am a phone this is my
this was gonna be my clues in such a
tiny man well I'm right here become this
become cold toast wait ice I want to see
if this works be and I home I can't the
[ __ ] you can't sit still toast
[ __ ]
I am NOT in the dark area you sure about
that yes I'm very sure cuz you say that
cuz you saw me checking there or did you
just oh how do you get out of here
don't mind me
[Music]
the original toast someone offered me
the toast I just use me the toast the
whole time yeah my jokes
drop it by Joe my toast my Joey are you
saying you were the toast the whole
toast and nothing but the toast
exactly exactly those words detective
mark pliers here ready to take this case
to the next level is you supposed to be
here wait I'm incredibly sorry I got
super excited about this I'll go back in
the toy
[Laughter]
where they are okay well why would you
want to kill one over the other you get
it wrong then we win yeah yeah have a
solution that was my solution about this
I'll be right back I'll be right back oh
yeah you wouldn't there's no way you
don't have a penis on you I'll call your
bluff first wins
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
okay boys I don't care it's very
tempting but I won't
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
why did you become it did oh did I can
you become the cigarettes I want to be
all yeah [ __ ] Marlboro Lights yeah I
want to get high and cigarettes
oh I'm 13 and ready to ruin my life
Wow don't smoke kids waited caught out
all the 13 year old smokers wait no no
you are not my role model anymore I had
to take them away from you Bob
I was just sucking on Jack that was not
nice
no no I wasn't smoking
I was just sucking on my good friend
[Music]